jeudi c'était la journée de la femme
Amanda Lear Martine Aubry et Michel
alliot-maris sont restés chez elle
presse de la semaine de Stéphanie
[Applaudissements]
politique une info libération Sarkozy
veut tester les immigrés exemple pour
trouver le futur Zidane organisons un
concours de Dream tous les immigrés
capables de passer trois rangées de CRS
balle au pied français
Sarkozy très inquiet par la situation
d'Airbus le futur gros porteur A380
aurait pu expulser 853 sans papiers d'un
coup ça fait trois bars HLM
l'UDF veut lancer des petits byrous
partout ouais tu peux encore le
miniaturiser Sarkozy non non
il disparaît
Simone Veil rejoint Nicolas Sarkozy bon
alors si elle l'accompagne à Argenteuil
les jeunes soyez gentils je sais qu'une
vieille avec un sac c'est très tentant
mais ne la traînez pas 30 mètres
derrière un scooter c'est quand même
madame veille
si Sarkozy passe Renaud donne Dieu de
Vabre souhaite conserver son ministère
quand il parle de culture même son chien
pionce
[Rires]
la villa de Ségolène Royal à Mougins
déclarait 270
000 euros office alors j'ai essayé de
trouver quelque chose à ce prix-là dans
la région j'ai fait une réunion
participative avec tous les agents
immobiliers dans ces prix il y a des
possibilités mais en dehors de Mougins à
Valbonne et c'est pas vraiment une ville
là c'est un camping-car mais c'est le
juste prix dans un monde juste
dans le magazine révolutionnaire gala
l'Alter mondialiste José Bové nous
présente sa maison écologique 100% pure
bois WC bio dégradable alors sachelingue
un peu mais comme José fume la pipe aux
toilettes ça va et au pire un coup de
déodorant Ushuaïa de chez Nicolas Hulot
Le Pen ne provoque plus de Huet au salon
de l'agriculture
est-il passé inaperçu il y avait
énormément de ports cette année
[Applaudissements]
une nouveauté a un robot pour traire les
vaches
l'agriculteur célibataire peut
éventuellement s'en servir
politique internationale à tous les Jedi
qui ont perdu leur jambe George Bush
offre un magnifique plaid ornée de
drapeau américain
attention ce qui perdent les jambes les
bras et la tête gagne un plaid de luxe
justice à RMI cette condamné à un mois
de prison ferme pour le vol d'un
sandwich alors
problème de CP quand ils étaient à la
mairie de Paris les époux Chirac ont
déclaré 2 millions d'euros de frais de
Bush partant du principe qu'un vol de
sandwich entraîne un mois ferme à quelle
époque de la préhistoire les chiracles
auraient du Net pour accomplir leur
peine
[Applaudissements]
l'ex directeur de voici mise en examen
150000 euros de pot de vin pour acheter
des reportages en même temps de l'argent
sale pour acheter des scouts de merde il
y a une logique merci
[Applaudissements]
pas trop voici
société jeudi c'était la journée de la
femme Amanda Lear Martine Aubry et
Michel alliot-maris sont restés chez
elle
de plus en plus de skieurs s'élance avec
bébé dans le dos
si bébé est nu une façon de le congeler
tout en faisant du sport
[Applaudissements]
showbiz de la rue est-il encore légitime
pour présenter de grandes émissions
sociétales oui réponse France 2 Jean-Luc
sait faire accoucher les témoins quand
il refuse de parler il est mort
et à ce propos attention alors en
exclusivité le nouveau logo de la
société de production de Jean-Luc
Delarue
inquiétude depuis que Philippe Torreton
a quitté Claire Chazal le comédien
s'habille en manteau de fourrure
[Rires]
match continue sa série nos vieilles
blondes se déploient après Arielle
Dombasle le mois dernier
c'est Michel Polnareff qui s'y colle
et on termine on termine par une info
qui ne concerne plus Orlando les Bourses
mondiales restent nerveuses
merci à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu